I think like hope is this really
important part of this you know the
families are all stuck in limbo right
now because they're without any evidence
they they need to believe that their
family members are alive last year a
boat of refugees disappeared somewhere
between Libya and Italy it was a boat
with 150 era trains on 90 something
Sudanese people on and it just vanished
completely
so we've been sharing as much
information as we can putting data out
there that we found helping people sift
through all of the information kind of
crowd source their way through it and
you know and try and track down what
might have happened to the boat what
route might have taken one of the things
we don't know is where if the boat sank
where it might say we've talked to
people on the ground who have given us
kind of direction and said for example
they've said oh you know a refugee boat
will use this oil or oil platforms or
lighthouses as beacons to navigate by so
we asked readers to go out and find out
and took map out the Libyan and Tunisian
coast
from talking to fishermen there who
often sail around in in the
Mediterranean and see dead bodies and
and watch people drift to shore they
pointed out the process that happens the
bodies are taken from the beach they're
thrown they they won't put them in an
ambulance because they stink and people
don't want to have to clean up so they
throw them in a garbage truck they drive
them about five miles outside zarzis to
this small landfill basically where the
bodies are thrown in the ground covered
over there's no markings there's no
records taken what we're seeing in this
investigation is that breakthroughs
often they don't necessarily finding the
people but they're they're exposing this
process you know casting sunlight on the
whole the whole mess there is power to
sharing a story there is power to
helping the voices of refugees reach the
public
you